I am arriving at football from research
and my presentation is on convex
optimization
all right so today I'm going to talk
about convex optimization and this is a
project been working out for about a
year and a half for two years and we're
finally releasing a bit of it which is
the good news and I'm actually using the
sort of a version 12 build for this so I
apologize for any bugs that show up
there are a few but they've been fixed
so so basically I'm gonna focus on
modeling techniques and then following
this talk there are two more talks one
by parrot OSH and Nena
on more details about the convex solvers
that we've developed for the new version
so so so so I guess I want to start by
talking about what you know why is why
is convex optimization a big deal wide
why does anybody care it's an
interesting I mean it's an interesting
field so I'm gonna try to explain that
I've taken a time line basically from
Wikipedia that I think sort of explains
why this is a big thing and why it's
worth thinking about
so phase in 1848 did this so I keep
working on stuff for he's done at some
point which is which is fun and
interesting okay in the late 30s
kantorovich formulated the general
linear programming problem and then and
at the same time in American economist
Koopmans formulated classic Edwin
promises and there were programming
problems and it turns out they both got
the Nobel Prize so so the linear program
is kind of Nobel Prize level type stuff
and one of the things is in in the 40s
Danzig developed a general linear
programming formulation independently at
them and he also developed the simplex
method which is an efficient way to
solve them and that was huge because
once he presented the simplex method
then people started using it another
thing he did is he had a discussion with
John von Neumann another one of my
numerical heroes that about about this
and Jonna and was said well you know
there should be this whole theory of
duality and I'm not gonna go much into
duality but paratah Shanina well and the
whole theory of linear programming
duality which gives you lots of
information about sensitivity and how
the constraints work carries over to
convex optimization as well so that's an
important important part of it so let's
go a little farther up
time okay and here's here's another big
step in 1979 Ketchikan so you can solve
solve linear program problems in
polynomial in polynomial time and then
car marker later published in 1984 an
interior point method which is actually
an algorithm for solving these in in
linear time so sorry polynomial time so
it solves linear programming and then in
late late 80s they started thinking
about these interior point methods for
non linear problems as well and they
sort of discovered that they could do
this with the convex problems as well
and so in 1994 this is probably the big
seminal paper and convex confirmation is
Nesterov and nemirovsky show that convex
optimization problems can also be solved
upon at that time you know I mean a huge
thing engine that drove all that was the
advance of numerical algebra various
techniques but basically these follow
the same type of techniques as the
linear programming problems and so the
reason that's a big deal is because
basically if if somebody tells you have
a linear programming problem you
basically know it can be solved you
neither determine it's infeasible or you
can you can solve it well the same is
essentially true of a lot of these
convex optimization problem so something
we have a whole big nonlinear class of
problems that we know we can solve or we
know we know we can determine in
feasibility so so we can we have a huge
class of optimization which which a lot
is known about and basically lately
there's been lots of demo in convex
problem classes which we'll be showing
you in the other talks the manses and
modeling techniques to get to convex
solvers there's some really good
packages cv x and y MF provide somewhat
comprehend and interfaces solver
libraries and we're trying to do here
the Wolfram language is ideal for
providing a nice interface to some of
these solve the libraries because we've
got the we've got the symbolic language
this is ideal for the modeling we can do
the transformation symbolically as
necessary so we've got an ideal platform
which I think we can eventually
we're not caught up yet but we're
getting there will be better than these
packages at doing that sort of thing and
also it's becoming a much more
mainstream
boy and Fanny Burney have done courses
online courses there's lots of textbooks
in it now so on and so forth so the big
upshot to take from this is that context
up image opens up a whole class of
non-linear problems that can now be
solved with efficient solvers in
appropriate modelling transformations so
let's talk about first I'll talk about
what what our special solvers are this
is this is coming and this is going to
be the so paradises been talked about
the first first for on those which are
basically linear and quadratic models
and then Nina's going to talk about the
last two which are which are more
esoteric models but they're just as just
as useful it just opens up an additional
class so what else is new okay is that
we've that our general optimization
solvers which are fine minimum and then
minimize they're not new but what is new
is that now what they do is they try to
do some transformation modeling from a
function to get to these convex solvers
and if they can they can solve the
process it all sort of opens up a new
class of problem I'll have an example of
that and another mention is that fine
minimum when you have a convex problem
and you get a solution you know it's a
global minimum so so you're either case
you're guaranteed and another thing that
convex optimization does very well is
fitting and we've added a fit
regularization off to fit as a as a
start of sort of additional build outs
from this okay what else is new are some
modeling tools that make it possible to
use these things efficiently with a
reasonable symbolic interface so one is
vector equality so I'll be explaining
those in a bit and then another thing is
vector and more generally array valued
variables with dimensional inference and
I'll kind of explain what that is but
you can basically have variables that
are matrices you know variables that are
vector valued and hopefully the system
will just work
with those so it opens up your modeling
thing so you can be even be much more
efficient and sort of natural in the
modeling language we also have parameter
constraint equations and I'll show some
examples of those we also have
transformation to efficient canonical
forms which allow us to get to these
solvers and I'll be showing you a bit of
how that works today as well okay so the
vector inequalities these are new and
they and you can probably guess from the
name they mimic our classic Mathematica
inequalities less less equal greater
greater equal now it's a little bit hard
to see in this font but you'll notice
that these signs are a little bit curvy
okay and that's the that's the symbol so
so the the difference between those is
that the the inequality sign is is a
little bit it's a little bit curvy so
let me show you
so the basic vector inequality is is
this so this is XY less than equal to
some P P is determined by locator so all
the points in the blue or where that's
true so the point so a point XY where I
have the mouse here it's true that it's
greater than equal to so it's a partial
order so now if I move this around you
know different sets of points work but
it's basically so let me give you a
couple more concrete examples so is 1 3
less than 2 for yes that's true okay
because 1 is less than 3 and 2 is less
than 4 okay is 1 2 less than a well we
don't know so anytime there's anything
symbolic in these we leave them pretty
much alone because that makes them
representations for the use of model
which is where they become really useful
okay but I can do substitutions so if I
do a goes to 3 okay that becomes true
now notice that a here is a scalar so it
sort of quote threads just like
arithmetic does in essence in fact
you'll see the actual definition of
these in a moment that actually
literally uses the same type of
threading model as a rhythmic
does okay I can also have a be some
higher-ranked thing now in this case
this is false because when the first
element comparison of one compared to
one that's not less they're equal so
therefore the whole thing is false so
any comparison fails the whole thing is
not false as you sort of saw from that
that graph it's only only the part of
the plane that's up or not they don't
have to be the same that's that's what
I'm saying they thread by arithmetic
okay I'll show also here's a more formal
definition for these okay that that
hopefully I answered eat ice question
okay the formal definition of these is
the generalized inequality X Y or
greater equal to Y gives true if X minus
y belongs to K where K is a proper
convex cone now the ones always the
default is this non-negative cone which
is the positive orthis or the positive
quadrant in the plane okay
so basically what you're actually doing
is you're doing I mean internally in the
kernel we don't do this approximate on
sand stuff that I could talk to you
about in extent but the the concept is
is subtracting this and seeing if it's
in that set okay but we can also extend
this to different different sort of cone
things and I'm not going to go into a
whole lot of detail about what these
cones are you'll see if a few pictures
in the next couple slides explain what
they are but there's a norm cone this is
often called the second-order cone such
that norm of the first n minus 1
components is less than you know the
last component okay
there's a semi definite column which
allows huge amount of modeling things in
terms of problems I'll show an example
of that where they're the set of semi
definite positive definite matrices so
that's that's one of these so you can
compare matrices now that are that are
symmetric
okay so let's look at the let's look at
the norm cone case okay so so here's a
here's a simple one so so this is this
is a comparison over the norm cone so XY
one is great to go to zero
well terms of the definition that's the
norm of XY is less than equal to one
which is just another name for the disc
okay so that's a that's a nice simple
one and one of the reasons these are
called cones is because well if I plot
this in 3d okay and allow the Z to vary
what do I get a lovely little calm so
that's uh that's I mean and all of these
all of these proper cones have have the
property that they're full dimensional
they go out to infinity and they have a
point that's one of the key things one
of these proper cones and that's what
allows you to make this partial order
with these generalized inequalities well
that's that's I'd like to talk to you a
neat eye about that sometimes because
it's basically you have to enter the end
right now you have to enter the input
form to get the box and then you can't
really edit it so so there might be some
issues with that okay so let's look at
this semi definite cone which is kind of
interesting things so let's compare say
this with the the identity matrix of two
so so that's telling me it's true but we
can verify that by checking the we take
the difference and then we do the eigen
values are the eigen values greater than
or equal to zero the answer is yes so
it's got to be true now this this one
requires the little extra stuff for
example if the difference is not
symmetric it can't be true because it's
you know it's symmetric positive
definite matrices so it needs to be in
the set X minus y needs to be in the set
we don't require that X or Y be in the
set but we do require the difference be
in the set okay let's look at it let's
look at a plot of these this is a so
here I'm showing and I put
quiet because there's some bug and
region plot that that it makes
complaints about these things hopefully
will get fixed but see this is actually
this is so this set goes out to infinity
but it's actually quartered curve and
it's actually the curve x times y equals
1 is the boundary for that so this is
another way of expressing x times y is
greater than equal to 1 is an equality
okay let's look at we can we can
actually move around the point let's do
a diagonal matrix I've done a diagonal
slider now if I move around now this one
is a little bit different it's it's yeah
so this is this is x1 Wow and y less
than or equal to some diagonal matrix of
D and we see the as you move this around
you can extend so that's kind of the
opposite direction inequality for the
set so so that's that's all I'm gonna
say about I think you know there's you
can probably have some fun exploring
these these new inequalities okay so
let's let's let's look at some of these
parameter constraint ideas so so we
actually had this in any saw before and
and what we can do is you if you define
things that look like constraints that
just have one thing on one side and you
don't call those variables the system
will interpret those as parameters okay
so it's it's a way of putting parameters
in without having to do assignment and
then we can say do something like this
so this is actually a regular eyes fit
problem that I've just done done right
here okay so so that's a convex problem
and it just substitutes the parameters
in at the right time so you can kind of
work with the equations efficiently
that's why I call them parameter of
constraints so you give it as if it were
a constraint but the system interprets
it and you can actually do that in any
salt you can give a bunch of equation
then you solve it you could have say a
equals five you know so it'll it'll do
that so that's actually we're for a few
versions in nd salt so so let's see why
we want to do that okay why might you
want to do that instead so let's try the
same problem just using an assignment
which is what you typically do right
right oh so I've set up
a function that does the assignment so
it sets up the assignment I want to keep
a the definitions local so I can
actually work with the code later in the
talk so if I do it with assignment oh my
gosh I get a spark of all sorts of mess
the reason this is this is complaining
is because that B is a vector and so
when it actually evaluates the norm it
threads across the components of that
vector B which are seven eight nine okay
and then the norm evaluates because norm
evaluates on a vector so I have this
thing and this is actually we have some
code that tries to recover
you know threading that was unintended
but this can't be recovered because the
order of these terms is completely
messed up so so there's nothing we can
do with this once once it's expanded
like that another alternative is you can
use inactive of plus okay and this is a
bug which has been fixed the missing not
available I fixed that this morning
you'll be happy to know okay and I'll
just mention that that this this problem
can now be done with fit with this fit
regularization so if I do fit rather
ization goes to one two it actually
gives me a sparse array because this is
something this type of problem is
sometimes called basis pursuit so you
may want to get a smaller basis we get
now the reason I had to put in Landover
two is it's a bug in bug which I fix
this morning as well so okay so let's
talk about model transformation event
okay so let's consider this problem so
if I introduce the following so let's so
basically the modeling transformation
you introduce variables or you transform
functions to get from one form to
another is the concept so I'm going to
introduce a new variable T which is the
absolute value of X so this is a this is
a this is a vector variable T okay and
I'm gonna say well I want t to be
positive it's got to be positive because
an absolute value right okay and I also
want to have it constrain the sides of X
which that makes it absolute value so
I've introduced that well then I've got
norm of X plus B well norm is quadratic
so I can just use quadratic optimization
that and I'm done so I'm basically with
once
up here I've gotten to my solver I can
solve it efficiently and we're done okay
so let's let's quickly quickly go into
convexity okay so a function is convex
basically if theta ax b'seder wise is in
a set a function is convex if it's this
I'm going to rather than go through them
don't have much time I'll just show a
picture of a classic convex function so
basically it's convex so if the function
value between this is less than this
line it's convex and this is this set
here I've shown is what's called the
epigraph of this convex function and it
is a convex set so any two points in the
set or connected with connected the line
that contains only points in the set so
what we can use convexity to is to
formulate the convex optimization
problem so so one is we want to minimize
so the classic convex our vision want to
minimize f of X subject to constraints G
of X less than or 0 subject to ask
affine the quality constraints
okay so f or convex functions H is often
now we can use the epigraph
transformation variation which is
instead of sort of like a transformation
like I showed before but we place we
replace F with T and f of X is less in
blue T that's kind of like that you just
be thinking about that graph I showed in
the previous slide so we can always
express a convex optimization problem is
a linear objective with been convex
constraints okay and that's really
important in getting to these these
solvers so let me give you an example of
a convex problem in a non convex problem
this problem is convex okay
we're talking about doing something on a
disc gets round everything in the
disconnects okay this one is not okay so
what's the difference
Circle okay you can't connect two points
on a circle with a straight line that
includes points on the circle it's just
not possible
so that's that's a good example I'm not
going to show the next part for interest
of time okay so a convex optimization
problem again is this so I've rewritten
it a little bit I've described it as a
linear function okay which I justified
by the last transformation with an F
fine equality constraints and convex
inequality constraint so another way of
expressing this is as follows so I can
express it as a dot X plus B 0 that's
the affine equality constraint and a and
a can be a matrix B can be a vector of
any size okay and these are now I've
written this in terms of our vector
inequalities or generalized inequalities
and I'm not going to prove this but any
function you can show that there's a
cone such that it is a coma - so this is
a completely general way of doing the
convex optimization problem now we're
not going to do that whole set we're
going to restrict to these following
cones kappa okay so that's it that's all
you get but I wouldn't worry too much
because this this is a pretty rich set
of functions that that Quall is you're
gonna be able to use okay so let's do
let's revisit the model transformation
I'm not gonna get everything I hope to
but I can certainly get through this one
so let's let's introduce let's use a
couple of transformations so this is an
ID I'm gonna introduce I'm gonna
introduce two three variables s t and u
okay so well I'll have s equals norm the
norm squared okay yeah s equals the norm
squared U is the norm so U squared is
less than equal to s okay and then I can
take the norm of AX plus B is less in
review and it also introduced T for the
1:1 norm and this is using that same F
of the epigraph transfer making you
think of the graph is the convex set I
use the convexity to be able to do that
and make it equivalent so now I can run
Konica optimization of that and I get
exactly the same the same function so
what art our model and stuff internally
does is it basically takes essentially
any problem you give it to find minima
and minimize and it tries to do
transformations like that to get into
what we call a canonical form which is
these conic constraints and so we've got
actually the conic optimization as a
function output auction called conic
constraints that allows you to to do
that now in general these are quite
sparse you notice like this last one is
a 9 by 7 matrix is only three positive
elements okay that's pretty typical and
you can actually hack it a bit and look
what the matrices look like so basically
these are all vector inequalities is
basically matrix times a vector of all
the variables and I've they're sort of
them and notice these are introduced
variables did you just automatically
introduce to do transformations that
need to do and then this is this is the
norm the other last or the norm come the
first one is the non-negative code okay
so I think and it was the time I have to
skip this other example it's a great one
but it shows how you can do so many
definite programming but I want to get
to the end of the talk and not take up
our Parra Tasha's time so so are we done
yet no we've got lots of things we're
planning to do so this is sort of a
first phase other things we hope to do
is we hope to integrate some commercial
libraries that if you have a commercial
license before you'll just be able to
use because some of these commercial
libraries I mean have some really
dynamite solvers that we just can't get
with the free libraries so so we're
gonna try to do that we'll have mixed
integer real convex optimization sort of
branch-and-bound type stuff multi
objective convex optimization and then
convex optimization with uncertainty or
stochasticity those are some definite
things we have in mind plus you know
building out use of convex optimization
throughout the language to do various
tasks as we can discover them so in
summary comments optimization is a
powerful tool it integrates really well
in the Wolfram language environment okay
so we have an
the classic problems that are just
they're basically solved
convex solver functions will have access
to certain deals here so you'll be
showing that in the next couple of talks
in addition there's a bunch of modeling
tools and Wolfram language inequalities
dimensional inference parameter
specifications and an automatic
transformation into to get too specific
solvers so thank you and I think maybe I
have a second or two for questions
[Applause]